embajador de francia en belarús nicola
de lacoste abandonó minsk bajo
circunstancias complicadas el gobierno
de alexandr lukashenko no dio ninguna
razón pero de lacoste dijo no haberse
reunido con lukashenko para entregarle
copias de sus credenciales tras haber
sido nombrado para el puesto el año
pasado
y permíteme enviarles hoy un mensaje de
despedida mi esposa y yo lamentablemente
tenemos que dejar belarús como saben
francia no reconoció el resultado de las
elecciones del 9 de agosto de 2020 y no
entregué mis credenciales
la represión de las protestas masivas y
de los opositores tras las elecciones
llevó a la unión europea a imponer
sanciones contra belarús lo que se sumó
a la condena a que el ejecutivo
bielorruso ordenara desviar un vuelo
comercial y aterrizar en minsk para
poder detener a un periodista de la
oposición además la atención se está
viendo agravada por la crisis
humanitaria en la frontera entre belarús
y polonia y lukashenko enfrenta
acusaciones por trasladar a migrantes
indocumentados a polonia y al báltico
razones por las que el ministro de
asuntos exteriores de letonia instó a la
unión europea a sancionar a la aerolínea
nacional de la vía por transportar a los
migrantes
entonces necesitamos aplicar sanciones
más estrictas especialmente si se tiene
en cuenta que belarús y lukashenko
todavía usan la migración como arma y yo
creo que se necesita considerar
seriamente aplicar más presión
belarús está cada vez más aislado
diplomáticamente y ya ha expulsado a
varios diplomáticos de su territorio
incluidos los de polonia lituania y
letonia